憂嘘
架空税鼻水がすごいでます肇社長ですはい時に今日の動画なんですけども申し訳ない
です非常にそうもないです
どういう道がないんですけども誰もが一度は行ってみたいと思ったことでしょうね釣っ
てます加工
あのこれアレですからイヤリングって言う方がピアスとかやリングって降参右に穴を
開けて足ってそこにこうやってなかっああんてやんなきゃいけないのをすごい痛いって
言ったじゃないですかだいたいが嫌なんでピアスとか開けないんですけどこれを使えば
誰でもなんかねふくその
イヤリング
できます的な雰囲気が例えばされますわかったりてここに海を挟んだよ
暑いですすり替えと言います耳があってここでこうこうやってネタ積んでするともう
ほらもうイヤリングですよ
どうですけどピアスっぽくなってませんか
car
[音楽]
100個買いました本当に100&がこれ1
2位
[音楽]
れちゃっ
[拍手]
ちょっと王閣これは取っといて合計100個の偽ピアスからというわけで今日はあの
誰しもが一度はやりたいと思いませんか顔中に100個のイヤリングをつけてみた
やってみたいと思いますあり非常にしょーもないけどさなんかピアスだけど人がいる
じゃないですか顔に目がすごい花とかついてる愛のみたらねすごいやのなんと思わない
んですけどまぁ一度行ってみたいなっていう興味本意ではあるというところでござい
ますどんどんつけて行ってみましょう
結構がっつりだどんどんつけてきますよいやーいいか追加ッ
もうこの時点でが付いた
方をヤンキーだけ濃い人いるんだ実際これ見たことある方原宿ではすげー
がすげーを綺麗で全然いる客いけますね入ってこういうのはにょ通っ
い離陸と思ったけど違うナンパいるいることでしょつけるのかな
唇がすごいねこんなに思いはってヤバイ
てきましたん
帰って破るうち100個つけることができました
良いんじゃねぇ
いってぇなぁ foot loose の本当に痛すぎてよくをこれすごくなるけど
これで100個の食べ合わせがこうにつけたは大体こんな感じになりたいですね
ここやけれど本当ですあと靴が弱りすごいですね
ブーブー
[音楽]
私だった
動画以下つです観光い
小川ってくそ出すですかーっ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
ばボランティアではどうぞよく時間の間行ってっ
2つけとろスプールサーフィンだよ強い
んでっ
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
あと釣りますこれ取れなんだよああ
生んだこれちょっとて二日でー